In the tree world, a balanced tree has
nodes condensed to only a few levels,
while an unbalanced tree has nodes
spread out among many levels.
The most extreme type of unbalanced
tree is really just a linked list,
where every node has only one child.
By that definition,
a self-balancing tree
is one that tries to minimize
the number of levels that it uses.
It does some algorithm during insertion
and deletion to keep itself balanced,
and the nodes themselves might
have some additional properties.
The most common example
is a red-black tree,
which is an extension of
a binary search tree.
As is painfully common
in computer science,
the name turns out to be
very straightforward.
In this type of tree, nodes are assigned
an additional color property
where the values must be either red or
black.
The use of color as red or
black is just a convention.
You really just need a way to
distinguish between two different types
of nodes.
The second property of a red-black tree
is the existence of null leaf nodes.
Every node in your tree that
doesn't otherwise have two leaves
must have null children.
As you can see, all null leaf
nodes must be colored black.
Next, if a node is red,
both of its children must be black.
There's an additional optional rule,
the root node must be black.
Lastly, for the rule that makes these
trees actually useful, every path from
a node to its descendant null nodes must
contain the same number of black nodes.
We'll see these rules in action
when we talk about inserting.
For now, know that these rules and
the last one in particular assure that
the tree never gets too unbalanced.